uh oh here comes another one
with Metro Vancouver's first major
pileup of snow came pileups of vehicles
there we go
as well as a fair share of frustration
and fear of the treacherous conditions
otherwise
some drivers in BC's Lower Mainland
region unprepared for the forecasted
snowstorm hitting hard during the busy
evening commute
and even many who had come equipped
became stranded into the early hours of
the morning I was stuck in the car more
than eight and a half hour I do have
snow Towers yeah
but nothing worked
no food no drink yeah and uh
I mean it's really disaster I can say
that even at midnight roads resembled
rush hour after strong winds and blowing
snow swept across BC's South Coast
[Laughter]
typically short drives turned into big
trouble hours-long Odysseys back to the
burbs I got home at 4 a.m an eight hour
commute home
thousands woke up without power
Wednesday most of the nearly 90 000 BC
Hydro customers had electricity restored
by midday but Crews were unable to reach
some regions on Vancouver Island because
of mass Ferry cancellations air travel
also affected with flight cancellations
and a passenger jet sliding off a
taxiway of Vancouver International
Airport we had a little bit of snow
in a first world country a G7 country
and we cannot handle it some drivers
Express their anger about uncleared
roads and Transit shutdowns as they
scramble to help each other create both
paths out of the snow and friendly
reminders to plan ahead
some kids jumping at the chance to enjoy
a snow day with many classes canceled
the province's hills and mountainous
terrain providing unique but familiar
winter challenges and while weather
warnings are still in effect in higher
elevations away from the water these
conditions are expected to taper off
into rain overnight
Global News Burnaby BC